PROFESSOR: So now
let's use the results
of our probabilistic
model of transmission
to see how we can
modify our safety
guideline to take into account
different risk scenarios.
So our general result is
that the expected number
of transmissions in the
room in a given time
is given by the expected
number of infected times
susceptible times
the mean transmission
rate, which is the average
beta times the time.
And we want this less to
be than some tolerance.
And also, given the
various approximations
we've made where,
for example, we
have not let the number
of susceptibles change--
people can be infected
more than once,
and we've neglected
various aspects
of the model in that way--
this should typically
be assumed less than 1.
So we're always kind of
thinking of transmission
of being a rare event.
If we have lots
of infected people
in the room, lots of
transmission going on,
that's a more
complicated situation
which requires more
sophisticated models.
But for purpose of
guidelines, this is the limit
that we want to think about.
But the different
scenarios correspond
to our different
assumptions about I and S.
So first, I'll just
remind you of what
we've been doing until now,
which is to limit spreading
of the epidemic as a whole.
Thinking what if every
indoor space were
to impose the guideline, we're
really thinking of the case
where I is 1, and
S is N minus 1,
and then this expected
number of transmissions
is just the indoor reproductive
number, which is, of course,
just N minus 1 times beta
tau is less than epsilon.
So that's the guideline
that we've already
been talking about because the I
and the S here are now actually
no longer random.
We're just saying let's just
consider that situation.
And if everybody
does that, then we
are limiting the spread
of the disease overall
and should be
hopefully fighting it.
What we'd like to
talk about here
is how to start with this kind
of a restriction which gives us
certain bounds on occupancy,
ventilation, and other factors
and think about,
well, how would we
actually remove that restriction
as the prevalence of infection
goes down?
So that's a bit of a
different question, which
is to limit transmission--
or maybe another way of
saying that more precisely
is new cases that are going
to arise in this indoor space.
So now we're not just saying
if an infected person enters,
we don't want any new cases.
What if we just don't want
new cases at all, including
taking into account the low
probability that somebody
actually does enter this
room who is infected?
So now I'll just remind
you of the results
from the last board
for that situation
with all the assumptions
of the previous model.
So the expected number
of I is now pIN.
The expected number
of susceptibles N
minus the expected
number, which is qIN.
And importantly then, the
expected value of I times S
is pIqI times N times N
minus 1, which was our result
from the end of the board.
And so now when we write that
we like the expected number
to be much less than
epsilon, expected
total indoor transmissions,
now notice instead of just
an N minus 1 like
we had before, we
have these additional
factors pQN.
And so we effectively
divide by that.
So in this case, we can
write our safety guideline
taking into account
the prevalence
as epsilon divided by pIqIN.
And so this allows
us as pI goes to 0
and qI goes to 1,
so in other words,
as the infection
becomes less prevalent,
then we can start
modifying our guideline
to increase this bound and,
for example, a lot more
people to enter the room or to
increase their time in the room
or to maybe turn down the
ventilation a little bit.
And we can make
changes like that.
It's typically considered
to be a high prevalence
infection when we're
getting, let's say,
in the range of
maybe 100 to 1,000
infected per 100,000
people in the population.
So that would be
0.1 to 1.0 percent.
This is really considered
usually quite high prevalence,
actually.
So there's quite a few
infected people around.
But in that case, if--
let's just say we
had a situation
with 10 people in the room
just to give an example then.
What would this tell us in
terms of increasing our time
in the room or our occupancy?
Well, occupancy is here fixed.
But let's say time in
the room or ventilation
or other factors.
We can basically
increase our N minus 1
tau, our cumulative
exposure time,
which is basically this
indoor reported number
that we're bounding.
This bound will increase or
increases by 10 to 100 times
because it's basically-- yeah.
This is an extra factor there.
So that means that if
the thing was telling us
that we could be in the room
for five hours, maybe now
it'll be 50 hours or even
500 hours actually depending
on how low the
prevalence actually gets.
And of course, as the
prevalence goes down further,
and the epidemic disappears,
we start to completely relax
our assumptions.
And we'll talk
about that shortly.
There's a third
risk scenario that
is also of interest, which
is to limit my personal risk
for a given individual.
So in this case,
we have a situation
where I only care
about myself, one
particular person in the room.
So the number of susceptibles
is now fixed at 1.
And the number infected
people is potentially
anyone else in the room.
So I'm worried about
attending event or being
in an office or some
situation where there's
a certain number of people.
And the number of infected
that I would expect would be--
expected number infected
would be-- well,
it'd be exactly equal
to pI times N minus 1.
So, basically, any other person
than myself could be infected.
And so that's the
expected number.
And of course, if S is fixed
at 1, then this expected value
I is also the
expected value of IS.
So my transmission rate
now has this factor.
And notice in this case, we get
the same N minus 1 as before.
But there's this
new factor PI here.
So that then tells me I
could express the bound
as the indoor reported
number is less
than epsilon divided by pI.
So, basically, we
have these factors
that come in when we talk
about prevalence that take
our previous bound
that brings in all
of the physical
quantities related
to the room, its ventilation,
filtration, viral deactivation,
time in the room, occupancy.
And we take those bounds.
And we can essentially
rescale them with these values
depending on how we are
using the guideline.
Now, this is a very
simple model but at least
gives us a sense of how
to make those decisions.
So, for example,
let's consider a case
like we did here where
if the prevalence is
in the range of 0.1% to
1.0%, which is actually
a fairly high
prevalence, then we
could increase the
bound on N minus 1 tau,
our cumulative exposure time, by
100 to 1,000 times as a factor.
So if the guideline
is telling us
that you have five
hours in this room,
it might actually be more
like 500 or even 5,000
for one particular susceptible
person given the prevalence
in the population.
So, basically, just
want you to keep in mind
that when applying
the guideline,
the basic ideas don't change.
We start with a bound on
this reproductive number that
brings in all of the physical
quantities and disease
quantities that we've
been talking about.
But we also may modify
that bound a bit depending
on our risk scenario.